hi I'm drew Carey I was in the movie
robots with Halle Berry I'm crank the
yellow robot and halley's the cute
silver robot Halle Berry starred in
Bulworth with Warren Beatty who
co-starred with Goldie Hawn and shampoo
who was in First Wives Club with sarah
jessica parker who was in Footloose with
you guessed it Kevin Bacon remember
Footloose it's that film from the 80s
about high school kids fighting for the
right to dance quaint right well believe
it or not we found our very own
Footloose story in the Arizona desert
somehow they knew we were coming well my
name is Spencer bell i'm a junior at asu
i'm going to william p carey school of
business for business management well my
name is Dale Bell and I along with my
son Spencer built the santan flat steak
house here in queen creek in arizona the
idea for Santana flat kind of came along
my dad and I were driving in a car and
my dad turned to me and said you know
Spencer what do you want to do with your
life what do you want to do for a job or
profession and I turned to him and I
said well you know I want to get into a
business a small business where Walmart
Costco another big box store is not
going to beat me up out of it he turned
to me and said well the only business
that I know of where he can do that is a
restaurant business when he suggested
he'd like to go into small business I
thought it'd be the perfect thing for
him to learn a small business and and
the difficulties involved in that and be
part of the American dream we have one
neighbor that actually lives on the
property that joins our property in his
name is Paul younger and he's a
beekeeper Paul initially was the only
person who showed up in opposition to
our rezoning I oppose it because of the
lights and the noise and smells and
traffic and everything else I thought
would be detrimental to our lifestyles
here when we were approved our plan was
approved by the county supervisors we
actually received a standing ovation
when the meeting was over and it became
obvious that we're that there are he was
going to get approval I asked him to
please have some consideration for the
neighbors he
her and he assured me that he wouldn't
it was exciting exciting to finally see
the doors open I was really pleasantly
surprised the impact was very minimal
and it's been a convenience to have of
course parton when people would walk
into the courtyard and see those
bonfires in this atmosphere this
ambience from all these old wagons and
buggies and all the antiques that have
been collected hear the word that most
often was was mentioned was awesome
people would say this is awesome Dale
and Spencer soon found out however that
not everyone was excited to see santan
flat open we weren't breaking any laws
but Pinal County apparently decided that
they did not like us and decide that
they want to put a noise ordinance in as
they did have a neighbor complain about
some of the noise and they put one of
the strictest in the state of Arizona in
fact the sound of a sewing machine is
louder than we are allowed to be with
our country western music venue here
Dale called and asked me if if the music
was too loud if it was bothering me or
anything else and I I really hadn't even
noticed it that much in addition to the
noise levels the county hassle Dale and
Spencer about everything from the size
of their parking lot to the number of
signs along the road and the kind of
wood they burned in their fire pits
daylin Spencer's efforts to comply cost
them more than a hundred thousand
dollars but County officials still
weren't satisfied they decided to invoke
a sixty-year-old ordinance dancing they
said in pinal county is illegal if it's
I've done outdoors there's an Arizona
County where's based on the county's
only which Dale and Spencer are fighting
in court each day santan flat patrons
are caught dancing Dale and Spencer must
pay a seven hundred dollar fine over the
course of a year the fines were total
more than two hundred thousand dollars
well there's there's no logic behind why
a government would not want to allow
dancing that I can come up with think
about I think it's ridiculous dancing is
an unman
the god-given right Dancing's too much
fun I stop it there's good music you
might as well dance have fun all I have
to say is crowd dancing is part of life
I think that it isn't is bad business as
far as the county is concerned we have
we've asked everyone everyone that we
know that would might have a clue as to
why pinal county would attack this
family-friendly good business and no one
has been able to come up with a logical
explanation maybe someone is trying to
use our County regulations to harass san
tan flats into either submission or into
some sort of a bankruptcy or financial
situation where it has to be put on the
market and sold and there are people
around here with money that would
probably be interested in buying it at a
real cut-rate had it not been for the
cover of the government's assault upon
this this venue this would been a just
almost a dream come true for a small
businessman because it was met with so
much support and praise because of this
experience I see how government can be
so abusive of its power even on a small
local level it doesn't have to be
federal even our pinal county government
is just way overstepping their bounds
they're going to have to take me on all
the way to the Supreme Court of this
state and wherever else we can go beyond
that if necessary because I don't
believe the government has any right to
tell people they can't express
themselves and they can't dance so if
you ever find yourself in Arizona on the
road between phoenix or tucson swing on
by San Tan flat I hear it's a great
place to dance Ariza TV I'm drew Carey
yes
were this freedom there's someone who
wants to take it and in Arizona is Pinal
County